مجددا طائراتك اذ تحلق فوق العاصمه
الروسيه
نحن نعلم من ارسلها وسنرد ولن يمر بسلام
وانزلنسكي المعارك طاحنه في بخموت
والمدينه على وشك السقوط فهل هذا مؤشر
لرفع الرايه البيضاء وحلف النيتو يعلن ان
اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الحلم
والاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تستنسخ الرئيس
الاوكراني والهدف حماايته ورئيس فاغنر
يفجرها نحن نراقب واشنطن من السماء وساحه
حرب جديده بين الروس والامريكان على حدود
روسيا الخارجيه الامريكيه تتوعد الرئيسين
الصيني والتركي والسبب دعم بوتين من تحت
الطاوله وموسكو ترد الدينا النووي
للصينيين واجراء عسكري ياباني يزعج الصين
الرئيس الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
الاجراءات الرد حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن نجاح الاختبارات الاخيره التي
اجريت على منظومات الدفاع الجوي في فرقطه
العسكريه الجديده التابعه للجيش رد بوتين
لم ينتهي حيث وقع الرئيس الروسي مرسوما
لتعليق العمل بميثاق مجلس اوروبا حول قمع
الارهاب وحمايه حقوق الانسان وغيرها وذلك
ردا على تحركات الغرب ضد موسكو وهنا دليل
على تحضير بوتين للرد تحت ستار الارهاب
والهدف الانتقام والحاق الضرر بمن كانوا
خلف تحليق الطائرات المسيره لنعد الى ارض
المعارك في اوكرانيا حيث اكدت كييف ان
الثلاثه الاشهر القادمه ستكون نشطه للغايه
وستحدد مسار الاحداث بينما يشدد الجيش
الروسي الخناق على قوات اوكرانيا في
داخموت لينطلق منها نحو مدينتي سل
فما الذي تخطط له قواتك للاشهر القادمه هل
سترفع رايتها البيضاء معلنه لفظ انفاسها
الاخيره في بخموت الحرب لا ترحم وكلما
طالت ايامها زادت الامها لتدفع صاحبها الى
الكشف عن الام جرحه هنا الرئيس الاوكراني
زلنسكي يقول ان المعركه محتدمه في محيط
بخموت التي تحاول روسيا الاستيلاء عليها
منذ اشهر وان الوضع صعب هناك فما كل هذا
الياس يا هذا ليمد الامين العام للبيت
الاوكران بالامل بقوله ان اوكرانيا ستصبح
عضوا في النيتو ولكن على المدى الطويل اذا
متى سيكون هذا الانضمام يا ستمبر هل بعد
ان تصبح اوكرانيا رمادا
الطويل بينما
الامريكان الحقيقه هناك حيث اكدت وزيره
الجيش الامريكي كريستين واشنطن يجب الا
تتهور في التقليل من قدرات روسيا العسكريه
حيث لم تستخدم موسكو بعده الى جزء يسيرا
من قدراتها الجويه والبحريه والسبرانيه
وفق وكاله النوفوستي ومن اصداء المعارك
الى مبادره السلام حيث خرج المتحدث
باسموف مصرحا ان خطه الصين لتسويه الازمه
الاوكرانيه تتمشى مع نهج موسكو مشيرا الى
ان المعاني الدقيقه في الاقتراح مهمه
باسكو اضاف ان روسيا لم تستانف المشاركه
في معاهده مع الولايات المتحده الى حين
استماع واشنطن الى موقف موسكو فهل حان وقت
الاستماع للروس ايها الامريكان ام ان
للحرب بقيه لياتي الرد من وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
الذي قال ان الصين لا يمكن ان تلعب دورا
مزدوجا عبر تقديم مقترحات للسلام بينما
تؤجج الحرب في اوكرانيا على حد وصفه وهنا
نعود قليلا نحو الحرب الاوكرانيه لذاتيه
الضربه للاوكران من واشنطن هذه المره وذلك
بتاكيد مساعده وزير الدفاع الامريكي
للشؤون الدوليه سلسه انه يتوجب على
اوكرانيا البدء في دفع ثمن الاسلحه
الامريكيه التي يتم ارسالها اليها وبعد ان
انتهت الضيافه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا امريكا
تطلب مقابل تلك الضيافه يا له من سخاء
حاتمي يا ابناء العم سام وهنا يفاجئ رئيس
فغنر الولايات المتحده بقوله ان ضاجنر
ليست بحاجه لشراء صور الاقمار الصناعيه من
الدول الاخرى فهي تمتلك 20 قمرا صناعي منذ
ما يقارب العام ونصف العام مشيرا الى
امتلاكها اقمار صناعيه تعمل بانظمه
الرادار للاستشعار عن بعد واقمار مراقبه
لمراقبه جميع الدول العالم باستخدام
اقمارها الصناعيه بما في ذلك وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وفق قوله ومن طباخ
بوتين الى نسخه زلنسكي هنا زلنسكي يحمي
زلنسكي اهل العجب انهما نسختان من الرئيس
الاوكراني فالاول هو زلنسكي والاخر هو
درعه الواقي وحارسه انه الرجل الذي يقف
خلف رئيس اوكرانيا في كل المحافل وهذا ليس
فيلما هوليوديا بل لاستراتيجيه جديده
الصين في خضم المعارك
انتهى عهد المجاملات وحان وقت المواجهه
هنا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
يتواعد باستهداف الشركات الصينيه والافراد
الذين ينتهكون العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا مضيفا انه اذا قدمت الصين مساعدات
عسكريه لروسيا فسيؤدي ذلك الى مشكله في
علاقات بكين مع الدول العالم فعن اي مشكله
يتحدث لكن وبرغم التهديد بتلك العقوبات
الدوليه فان الصين تتجاهلها لتزود صناعه
السلاح الروسيه بالرقائق الدقيقه واشباه
الموصلات وهو الامر الذي تفعله تركيا كذلك
بحسب بولس كانهم يقولون ارونا عقوباتكم يا
هؤلاء حرب الرقائق تتواصل وفي اطار تعاطي
اداره بايدن مع الملف الذي عاد للواجهه
مجددا ضمن نطاق الامن القومي الولايات
المتحده تعمل على نقل صناعه اشباه
الموصلات التايوانيه الى امريكا ومن معارك
اشباه الموصلات الى حرب الاختراقات الجويه
حيث كشفت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه عن رصد
تسعه عشره مقاتله تابعه للقوات الجويه
الصينيه في منطقه الدفاع الجوي التايواني
لننتقل الى ما هو اعظم فها هي روسيا ترد
الدين للصين وذلك بتصدير ما يقرب من سبعه
اضعاف كميه اليورانيوم عالي التغسيل الى
الصين خلال الفتره ما بين سبتمبر وديسمبر
الماضيين
وهو ما يمكن ان يساعد بكين على زياده
مخزون الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه بنحو اربعه
اضعاف للسنوات الاثنتي عشره المقبله فيا
لها من بوادر خطيره لصراع نووي يمكن ان
ينهي العالم لكن هنالك يتحضر لمواجهه
التنين الصيني نعم انها اليابان وسعيا
لمواجهه اطماع الصين العسكريه في اسيا بدا
الجيش الياباني اجراء تعديلات على عقيدته
العسكريه وفي هذا الصدد تحولت جزيره يونا
جوني المعروفه بالطبيعه المسالمه لقاعده
عسكريه تضم رادارات تراقب تحركات الصين
العسكريه في المنطقه
الاحداث والتطورات الرئيس الفرنسي امامويل
يقول ان اطرافا فرنسيه وجهت ضربه لباريس
لمحاوله افشال التقارب مع الجزائر وذلك
باستقطاب ناشطه المدونه باحكام قضائيه
جزائريه امير بوراوي من تونس فماذا لو عاد
معتذرا يا اهل الجزائر المبعوث الامريكي
هادي عمرو يصل نابلس ويقول انهم سيتخذون
اجراءات لمنع التكرار الاعتداءات على
الفلسطينيين بينما كانت واشنطن قد ادانت
هجوم المستوطنين على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين
في نابلس مطالبه تل ابيب بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن العنف انتم تكذبون كما
تتنفسون اوكرانيا التي وعدت الغرب بعدم
استهداف الاراضي الروسيه ها هي تستهدفها
اليوم فكيف سيكون الموقف الغربي من ذلك
[موسيقى]